c'est ici qu'on s'est rencontrés oui
vous étiez mon seul témoin
plus
je serais incapable de vous expliquer
pourquoi je te retrouve ici en 89 une
chose est certaine c'est tout se passe
exactement comme d'entasser vous allez
je redis ce que vous allez
ce n'est pas les sensations je ne peux
pas aller au commissariat parce que j'y
suis déjà
il va y avoir d'autres meurtres le
personnel va faire encore trois victimes
c'est en train de dire que vous pouvez
empêcher des meurtres d'être commis
c'est bien ça j'écoutais un malade va
s'en prendre à une jeune femme et it's
you do mar renvoyer des ormes
immédiatement
moi qui donne les noms des victimes vous
m'aviez dit exactement comment ça allait
se passer et ce en transformant suspect
numéro un c'est ça j'ai besoin de votre
aide et les
ce que vous allez faire maintenant
très bien
lâche ton arme
autant toi